now it's worth pointing out I actually
haven't found stationary points
yeah because points require a coordinate
or y value as well I could find them
right now if I wanted to there's no like
order that's required here I'm going to
go straight to a workout the nature of
this guy actually so what am I going to
do well in the past what I would have
done is I would have said okay let's
make a table of values
let's go zero let's go three here's a
good example of where this stationary
points actually cut far apart right do
you see that so I would say even though
one and a half is in between those
that's that's really far in terms of the
actual distance from the stationary
point so I would encourage you to go
closer to the stationary points not just
halfway between that's what I would have
done if all I had was the first
derivative but now I have the second
derivative and I know what it means so
I'm going to take these guys and I'm
going to say test second derivative and
I'm gonna do it once for each value
right so I'm gonna say x equals zero
means that the second derivative is what
have a look it's zero okay I'm gonna put
that in my back pocket for a second I've
got another station if weight x equals
three and I'm going to test that value
as well well let's see here
12 times nine is a think so yes 24 times
3 is 72 that sounds like 36 yeah did it
I can do arithmetic yes okay great now
this is a really important spot it's so
important I'm gonna put it in another
color because a lot of students sort of
gloss over this next part but it's a
critical piece of the mathematical logic
of do you know what a second derivative
means what are you doing with it okay so
this point here in your normal working
obviously you know to change color I
just really want to highlight this for
you okay what I've now done is I've got
a value for the second derivative and
what matters about the second derivative
is its sign is it going down is it going
up what's it doing okay so I want you to
make a statement about its sign
were to say at this particular value of
x at x equals 3 the second derivative is
positive okay what does that mean if the
second derivative is positive if that
makes a statement about concavity right
so I want to say that I understand what
the second derivative means if the
second derivative is positive then it is
concave up or down it's up cos positive
but that in turn means if it's concave
up it's a minimum do you see that
concave up means bid of them so I'm
gonna say concave up a minimum turning
point okay
that abbreviation is pretty well
accepted in this context okay it's
really vital that you actually say all
of that a lot of people will go straight
from here to say minimum there's two
problems with that
number one I don't think you
successfully or convincingly
communicated that you know what that
means like it could be just you memorize
that a value like that is meant to be
that you've seen a whole bunch of
examples okay so the first thing is it
doesn't fully communicate your thinking
process secondly we're armed as you go
to see once we step back from this
particular question our mind is being
filled with a lot of different processes
right now and so you're very liable to
forget what's going on on the most
common error at this point is to say
okay second derivative it's positive
positive positive is big big sounds like
it's a maximum like a full 30% of people
in their first exam where they get
assessed on this they look at the number
they see it's a big number that's a
maximum which is the opposite of what it
means because these students clearly do
not understand what can cavity is and
what the second view says about it okay
now if you just go straight from here to
here what I like it it to is like when
you memorize a formula but you don't
really understand what the formula is
and so it's very easy to remember it
wrong because you have no mechanism to
work out what the right thing is okay so
that's why two reasons please do not go
straight there number one said you
communicate you understand what is going
on number two when you actually force
yourself to say con
cave up saying those words presuming you
know what concavity is sort of should be
a bit of a mental cue you like wait
which way is this thing face you again
oh yeah that's a clearly looks like a
minimum right in fact when I was going
through this I often literally drew a
little thing over here just as a mental
cue in much the same way as when you're
testing with the first derivative you
would do something like this underneath
your table values remember I showed you
how to do that you don't have to do that
that's for you it's not for the marker
okay so why have we done we have found
that x equals three is going to be a
minimum that's good I do want to know
what the point is so let's go ahead and
find the Y value where am I going to do
that we're going to put x equals three
right back at the original function so 3
to the power of 4 is 81 minus 4 times
that's what I don't know what 4 times 27
is I want to help me out someone go to
calculator what's Y gonna be equal to so
with that that sounds negative 27 pinky
oh yes so it's are you saying it's
anyone take away underneath so what you
think which is that anyway let's go all
right so what do we done so far
what have we established ok 3 comma
negative 27 3 comma negative so that's
the coordinates of the what did we say
it was it was a minimum set up okay
now you will notice that I artfully
dodged this guy I'll sort of left him
alone okay I'm almost certain based on
what this graph is is a horizontal point
of inflection however I don't actually
know that that's the case and to
illustrate why I actually want you to
maybe on the side of your page or even
on a whole new page I need to show you a
really important counter example to this
and just saying it's a horizontal point
inflection okay so somewhere else beside
this if you have space on another column
or just on our brand new page I just
want you to consider a simpler function
I want you to consider this one okay
this is a very very important point a
very important function because it
illustrates why
this doesn't guarantee our horizontal
reflection let's have a look at it if I
went through exactly the same process
just to make it a bit quicker I'm just
going to differentiate these micelles if
I went through this exact same process
to find any kinds of stationary points
and then determine their nature you get
something unusual a lot of this is going
to map out exactly the same because you
in fact you see a lot of the same kinds
of numbers between this function and
that function okay you're going to find
a stationary point at x equals 0 x
equals 0 happens to also coincide with y
equals 0 so the origin you know you have
a stationary point so you might think
okay I will go to the second derivative
to find out what kind of stationary
point it is but of course at x equals 0
what is the second derivative also 0
okay so what does that mean well
underneath here you can draw this for me
why cause X to the 4 is a very simple
graph you could probably have a good
guess as to what it looks like it
basically looks like a parabola that's
gained a bit too much weight and it's
sort of fat down the bottom so you can
see down here it just kind of levels off
in a way that a parabola doesn't it sort
of picks up in a steeper way okay so for
all intents and purposes it looks just
like a parabola it's not by the way
because it's not a quadratic okay you
know is that a point of inflection think
about what I described that when we talk
about the second derivative what is a
point of inflection I don't have my own
my really handy steel right here
what's the base word under inflection
flex right there's a bend of some kind
okay it bends from being concave one
direction to concave another okay now is
that point there one point where the
bend changes and the answer is no look
at the concavity think about the cup of
the game right before this mystery point
before the origin it's concave up or
down it's clearly concave up right and
then when you look afterwards you're
like oh it it's still concave up right
in fact it's concave up everywhere
except for there okay so what would we
describe this as you can actually label
this there is no change in concavity it
doesn't change from concave up to down
or from concave down to up it just stays
concave up the whole time so because
there is no change cavity what that
means is there is no point of inflection
because that's what a point of
inflection is it's a change in concavity
that's what it means some textbooks
unfortunately they sort of confuse these
things together they're like look when
it's equal to zero it's fair 95% of the
time you'll find a point of inflection
there okay but this is the perfect
counter example and it's it's not a hard
one to find it's not like weed and
complicated where this doesn't actually
happen okay so therefore we actually
have to do a little more work if there
is a change in concavity how will I know
that think about how I knew it over here
yeah if there really is a change in
concavity then on the left
it'll be say positive and on the right
will be negative or vice versa
okay so there's no way to escape this
you have to test on either side that's a
bit of a pain
I admit now basically at this point here
you know how we are you know how we were
trying to get away from testing a table
of values cuz it's like oh it's a slow
thing to use the first derivative and
test for table values at this point for
the second derivative you have to test
the table of values it's for the second
derivative not the first one because now
I'm trying to work out is this a point
of inflection or not and that takes a
little more work okay so what I'm going
to put I'm not going to worry about
finishing than that right now I'm just
gonna say from here you need to have a
table of values for this second
derivative okay
I don't worry about that right now I
just wanna show you how to use it to
test determine the nature of stationary
points okay so do any questions does it
make sense let me just step back you got
to find the stationary points first we
know how to do that but instead of going
to a table values to test to determine
the nature you go to the second
derivative instead so you actually have
this choice to make okay